two people two states the same crime
both people say they were swindled while
they were trying to sell jewelry online
these bait and switches are not new but
as john langler reports people are still
being fooled
we're all used to the trap you see
something being sold online maybe on
ebay or facebook everything from cars to
furniture to diamond rings well
sometimes the price is too right
beautiful it's 191 diamonds mary wassink
posted this necklace on facebook's
marketplace quickly she had a buyer
willing to pay nearly eleven thousand
dollars so last week they met at a
california bank he got the jewelry and
she got the money
just not all of it a minute later if
that i opened up the envelope and it was
all ones
so the 10750 was gone and it was
replaced with 100 ones and a 100 bill
that money was supposed to help her son
go to college first you feel like oh my
gosh am i that
stupid
wasing went back to facebook marketplace
to tell her story she found out she
wasn't alone brian daniely lives in las
vegas he says he's met the same buyer as
wasink at the bellagio he was trying to
sell his 19 thousand dollar rolex he
hands me the envelope says put in your
pocket when i saw the money counted it
gives me money i put in my left front
pocket i didn't think to take it out of
the envelope danielle told casino staff
and metro police he's also talking to
detectives in redondo beach california
where wasink was scammed the cases are
under investigation there's a ton of
people out there with the same issue 13
that i found so far in the meantime both
sellers have learned very expensive
lessons john langler 8 news now